you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme bp announces plans to
accelerate its green commitments after
recording its highest annual profits for
eight years
government sources tell sky news they're
unaware of any treasury request to the
business secretary after the chancellor
is accused of trying to fast-track oil
and gas projects
and the un warns that 13 million people
in east africa are facing severe hunger
because of drought
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now it's one of the biggest oil and gas
companies in the world and now bp has
just got bigger recording its highest
profit in eight years it's the second
oil giant to record huge earnings in a
week after shell announced more than 14
billion pounds in profits
but it comes as many people are facing a
cost of living crisis with soaring
energy bills
so the calls for a windfall tax have
grown louder but bp's chief executive
pushed back today saying that that tax
wouldn't fix the problem and he promised
to transform the company into a low
carbon energy business so let's take a
look at how bp is investing in a green
future well the oil and gas major today
reported profits of 9.5 billion pounds
for 2021 now that's after a loss of 4.2
billion pounds the previous year now the
company previously said that it would
cut its operational emissions by between
30 and 35 percent by
2030. well today they announced that
they would accelerate those plans and
halve their emissions by then
well bp also announced plans to increase
investment in low carbon energy such as
electric vehicle charging renewables and
hydrogen to more than 40 percent of
total spending by 2025 and to 50 percent
by 2030. our business correspondent
helen ann smith reports
let's go to the wall
struggling it seems is now standard
i've used up all my savings what is this
additional cost to living going to do to
disabled people food is expensive
petrol is expensive
a small selection of people on a sky
news show speaking to a nationwide
squeeze
but many are also enraged and this is
partly why
laid out in a glossy presentation the
high prices forcing bills up have made
bp billions in profit
the oil giant made 12.8 billion dollars
last year that's about 9.5 billion
pounds
it was a similar success story at its
competitor's shell 17 billion dollars
for them and it's a dramatic turnaround
from 2020 when the pandemic and plunging
oil price led bp to losses of nearly 6
billion dollars
it'll mean larger dividends for
shareholders but there were promises too
on how some of that extra cash will be
spent we need to accelerate the
transition for every pound that we make
in britain we're going to invest two
pounds at least
but for many that's just not enough not
for the first time the profits of these
private companies is becoming political
amidst a severe cost of living squeeze
where as many as a quarter of uk
households could be facing fuel poverty
many see billions of pounds in profits
as deeply unpalatable calls are mounting
for the chancellor to claw some of it
back
and that could be in the form of a
windfall tax a one-off tax on those
profits
it's the solution labour would like but
the reality could prove complicated a
wimpful tax is a very good and easy
political statement but actually levying
it
targets not just pension funds but it
also might take money away from the
green transition as well well i don't
accept that actually if you look at who
owns bp's shares a very small percentage
of it is owned by
pensions pension funds and more broadly
these fossil fuel companies are not
primarily investing in the green
transition with this money this is going
back to shareholders and share buybacks
oil companies already pay higher tax
than other firms but bp's boss has
described it recently as a cash machine
wounding words when poverty for some
seems the price of profit for others
helena smith sky news
well alongside these big profit
announcements are reports that oil
extraction in the north sea is expanding
according to the daily telegraph the
chancellor has requested that the final
approval of six new oil and gas fields
currently under consideration is
fast-tracked to deal with the enemy
energy crisis
so what is really happening in the north
sea well skies a climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter is
here to explain so hannah what's going
on then behind the scenes
very interesting story this one
anyway you've got the north sea
situation which is awkward for the
government you've got
an ongoing fossil fuel extraction
industry working away off the uk's
shores which doesn't go so well with the
uk's position as a globe global leader
on on on climate change and now you have
this new reporting in several national
newspapers that the chancellor himself
asked the business secretary quasi
corten to fast-track the approval of
several new licenses
in the north sea now government sources
have told sky news that that
absolutely didn't happen didn't
recognize any characterization that the
chancellor had inserted himself into
that process i think it's also worth
saying that those you know that report
or those sets of reports is it's very
difficult for the government because in
previous periods particularly in
relation to controversial oil fields
like cambo for example uh the business
uh secretary and others have been an
absolute pain to say we can't get
involved in what is an arms length
regulatory process that would be
improper we don't have the power to do
so
um you know separately the north sea as
a story for the government as an awkward
story for the government uh isn't going
away it's trying to walk a tightrope at
the moment
there are some within the government
obviously who want to keep the north sea
fossil fuel industry going
if not to collect more tax as they earn
more profits but to keep big companies
in place so that they can invest in
renewables
in the uk but there are others within
the government like alok sharma and
conservative mps who are saying we have
to move away from fossil fuels and
further and faster so we can get to
renewables we can make that transition
happen faster because we are supposed to
be a global climate change leader
hannah thanks very much indeed
well let's take a look at how oil and
gas contributing to our energy in great
britain right now and you can see on our
data dashboard here that gas is
currently making up about a third just
over a third of our energy mix at the
moment and renewables which includes
things like solar but mostly wind
taking up about a bit over 37 percent
and here you can see the global co2
emissions that number ticking up all the
time
well now for some of the other climate
news of the day and nature-friendly
farming such as introducing measures
like ditching artificial fertilizer or
boosting hedgerows could slash the uk's
carbon emissions equivalent to taking
900 000 cars off the road that's
according to a new wwf uk report the
charity is calling on the government to
set out a path to slash greenhouse gas
emissions in farming by more than 35
percent by 2030 which could help boost
populations of vulnerable species
before the cop 26 we saw this big plan
come forward but there was a piece
missing of that jigsaw and that is that
land food and agriculture strategy and
we need to make sure that now for
farmers that's what they're calling for
and for environmentalists as well we're
saying this
jigsaw it's a big opportunity let's take
that opportunity and move forward
germany has appointed the executive
director of greenpeace international as
its new climate envoy jennifer morgan is
taking on the role in germany's new
centre-left government after the country
pledged to reduce its emissions
italy's government is working on a new
multi-million euro package to help
consumers with the rising cost of energy
the urgent package worth at least five
billion euros is an attempt to cushion
the blow of rising prices as europe
tries to cope with one of the worst
energy crunches in history the
government has allocated 10 billion
euros since last july to tackle energy
bills
now the united nations is warning that
millions of people are facing severe
hunger in the horn of africa due to
record droughts now according to the
world food programme an estimated 13
million people across ethiopia kenya and
somalia are facing severe hunger in the
first quarter of this year because of
drought conditions now it's prompted a
regional drought response plan for the
horn of africa calling for
327 million dollars with
4.5 million people in immediate need of
help well in somalia in 2011 a severe
drought contributed to a famine killing
260 000 people
and now the world food programme
predicts that the number of acutely food
insecure people is expected to increase
from 3.5 to 4.6 million between february
and may 2022
a warning that our africa correspondent
john sparks's report includes images of
animals which have died because of the
drought
the crops have withered
the grass has turned to dust
and the animals that support millions
are dying
where seasonal rains brought life to the
borderlands of ethiopia somalia and
kenya
bone dry winds now blow
it hasn't rained here for three years
most people here are pastoralists they
follow their animals and live from the
land
but the shortage of water has driven
many into camps
thousands live here in this ad hoc
settlement in ethiopia
and the aid agencies are struggling to
feed them the un says 13 million are
facing severe hunger
[Music]
others still crisscross the territory
searching for water if their livestock
can manage it
but if the animals die malnutrition
typically follows for they are the only
source of meat and milk
unicef says hundreds of thousands of
children are now at risk of severe
malnutrition what will happen in your
view if we don't get
significant rainfall
in april
oh god no this i mean
it is a possibility
which i would not like even to think of
but i mean professionally i have to
and i think
it can be a real catastrophe a huge
catastrophe
in somalia the drought has been
particularly fierce 90 percent of the
country has been affected
and many have abandoned their homes in
search of food and water
aid agencies say there is still time to
act with the lives of millions are at
risk
john sparks sky news
[Music]
and finally a film that we've talked
about a fair few times on this show has
been nominated for an oscar the end of
the world satire don't look up is up for
best picture after prompting some varied
reviews the film's director adam kaye
said he was inspired to write the movie
by his terror about the climate crisis
do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
seppi golzari monroe deputy director of
the energy and climate intelligence unit
and david wallis wells journalist and
author and we'll be discussing the big
oils big profits and global food
production do we need systemic change
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
deputy director at the energy and
climate intelligence unit sepi golzari
monroe and journalist and author david
wallace well so good evening to you too
so first of all renewed calls today for
a windfall tax on oil and gas companies
as bp posted record profits for 2021.
now profiting from high energy prices
while consumers are hit by ever higher
bills
these results follow big losses in 2020
and bp is talking big on climate targets
by 2030 half of its spending will be on
low carbon energy rather than oil and
gas but is that enough so seppie bp's
profits may be hard to stomach for some
given
the the rising energy bills that people
are contending with not to mention the
climate crisis
but the company themselves argued that
they're trying to fund a hugely
expensive shift towards greener forms of
energy so
they they would say
leave us alone we need to make these
profits
well it appears that their plans towards
uh these uh more investment and
renewables were actually made before
uh the they understood the extent of
their profits uh for for this year so um
i'm not sure that their plans are
predicated on the profits that they've
made this year but also actually you
know we we've seen that they are
giving out uh you know money to their
shareholders they're they're paying that
money out and and it really you know
it's appealing for some to think that
actually well you know that money could
be used instead to alleviate this uh
cost of living crisis that so many in
the uk are facing
david what's your take on this do oil
companies need these big profits in
order to fund the transmission to
greener alternatives
well they're private companies to the
extent that they are participating in
this transition
they require some capital but i'm
skeptical that their motivations are as
pure as their um as their leaders
suggest i mean when you look at this
spending it is significant um i don't
want to say it's nothing but they're
still spending considerably more money
opening up new oil and gas capacity
which is in direct violation of what the
iea said was necessary um to allow the
world a chance of staying
to 1.5 degrees of warming they said that
meant no new investment in new oil and
gas infrastructure at all going forward
starting today um and bp is among the
best performing oil and gas companies
when it comes to the renewable
transition and yet still this they're
spending considerably more money on the
old dirty kinds of energy than on
building out their renewable portfolios
so i think we have to understand some of
the you know they are making a shift
here but the scale
of that shift is as important as the
fact of it and the scale is um according
to the iaea and the ipcc i'm still
woefully into fiction
sepi yet they would argue no doubt that
we still do need these fossil fuels
while we transition we still need gas in
this country for example
until there's enough renewable
infrastructure there to replace it
i mean i think that just just looking
again at the um the the the actions and
not words just wanted to highlight sorry
anna that the the investment in
renewables from bp actually halved
between 2018 and 2019 so i think i agree
with david that we need to see some more
um action and not just words and on your
point about you know the the
need for fossil fuels well that's that
is in the
ccc's pathways et cetera but it's vastly
reduced we know that we don't need any
new uh oil and gas but also we we know
that actually the ia who are not a
radical body by the way uh
they're very conservative actually have
said that it's not only that we
shouldn't go after the new oil and gases
that actually if uh countries listened
to their advice on the pace at which to
pursue renewables countries and
companies then we just wouldn't need uh
as much oil and gas uh
as you know these companies are
suggesting so i think we just need to be
quite careful you know we've already got
so much knowledge about the reserves
that are available that are extractable
we know that we need to keep much of
that in the ground anyway so it just
seems like throwing good money after bad
to pursue new investments here
and and david you're in the states at
the moment and there there are hearings
going on looking at various fossil fuel
industries um sustainability pledges and
examining them i mean how
much awareness public awareness is there
of what's going on and could this prove
to be some kind of watershed do you
think could it shift public opinion on
on what's going on
well i don't think these hearings in
particular are going to make mark a
dramatic break in public opinion but i
do think that we're living through a
relatively rapid cultural shift that is
um you know
meaning more and more people are
regarding and treating the fossil fuel
business as a kind of a villainous
entity in our in our lives and our world
um it's not the matter of one hearing um
or one climate summit or one
report but i do think that that shift is
moving forward i think that's one of the
main reasons why so many of these
companies are at least paying so much
lip service to the um to the green
transition they don't want to lose
a custom customer support and the
cultural cachet that they've had in the
past or at least don't want to lose it
as quickly as they might otherwise
otherwise lose it um but you know
whether or not what what that means in
terms of emissions under production i
think is is very much an open question
and there was a big new study that came
out yesterday wasn't just looking at oil
and gas companies but 25 major um
multinational corporations who had made
net zero pledges and found that actually
in aggregate those net zero pledges only
amounted to a reduction of about 40
percent of those companies emissions um
not 100 does the term net zero implies i
think we're seeing something quite
similar um across the economy maybe even
most especially in the fossil fuel
sector where companies are saying that
they're moving much faster than they
than they really are
okay interesting well let's move on to
our second topic right now because a
complete change in the way we produce
food could be one of the big solutions
to climate change not only could
regenerative farming help biodiversity
claims a new report from the world
wildlife fund but the emission savings
would be the equivalent of pulling
nearly a million cars off the road in
the uk
so sepi uh the wwf who did this report
say that farming and nature have to be
front and center of the government's
plans to hit net zero the government
though would say it's already shifted
its policy on farming towards being more
environmentally friendly that the nfu
the national farmers union would say the
same so how necessary do you think this
call is
well i think we just need to look at it
in the round and as you say you know the
uk
is making steps i would say that it's
not uh quite
there yet you know there's still a lot
of policies that need to come into place
to make sure that farmers are supported
to work with nature and not fight
against it in order to make a living but
i think more broadly you know taking a
step back and thinking about actually
what do we need to do with our global
food system um you know including in the
uk to actually have an impact on climate
change it's really you know really
strikes you that we need to look at food
waste as well as amongst all of these
other kind of more um headline grabbing
um options because you know food if food
waste were a country it would be the
third biggest uh emitter actually it's
kind of it contributes up to 10 of
global greenhouse gas emissions so
there's a lot that it's a very complex
system and there's not kind of just one
one solution that's going to kind of be
the silver bullet here unfortunately
david would you agree with that i mean
and and farming obviously a big business
in this country but in the states it
really is enormous isn't it
yeah and it's dominated by by big ag in
a way that um is almost unimaginable
elsewhere in the world um i i mostly
agree i think that um these practices
these innovative techniques um maybe
some little miscellaneous innovative
because some of them are sort of ancient
i'm just repurposed for
modern ends um they can make a
difference they're really important to
implement they can um really
meaningfully reduce our emissions in the
uk and around the world but they
themselves will not solve the problem of
food emissions and the report that you
mentioned i think said that um
implementing these
these practices would be the equivalent
of taking 900 thousand cars off the
british roads and that's really
significant on the other hand there are
i think 32 million cars in the uk right
now so we're not talking about um as
episode a single silver bullet solution
it's one tool among many many many that
we'll have to implement important but
not sufficient on its own yeah and and
certainly there's there's a focus on on
issues like hedgerows and fertilizers
for example in the rapport but
ultimately
is what's going to really make a
difference as far as agriculture and
emissions is concerned
people changing their diets and eating
less meat
look i mean i think uh you know the
eating less meat point is is quite um
i think it's it's quite complicated
because not all meters is made equal and
you know there's a huge difference
between you know um a car reared on a
tree-covered hillside in in northern
england um with kind of the beef that's
imported from brazil on on lands that's
been deforested you know like that was
part of the amazon previously so i think
it's it's it's really difficult to kind
of make these um broad statements i
think what we can see is a trend amongst
brits that you know they're just eating
less meat anyway both for kind of the
planet but also for their own health i
think it's something around 17 percent
uh less meat being consumed by by brits
on an annual basis and so there is a
trend there but i think again we just
need to be a bit nuanced about the when
we're talking about you know uh meat
because it's just it's it's not all the
same it doesn't all have the same kind
of carbon intensity and some
forms of agriculture uh you know with
with um
cows and sheep can actually help
regenerate the land as well okay we must
leave it there sorry to cut in sepia
monroe and david wallace wells really
good to see bo thanks very much indeed
and that's it from me but tomorrow i'll
be joined by climate justice activist
michaela loach and chairman and founding
director of climate change think tank
e3g tom berg but thanks for watching
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you